how did you feel the scenario played out
holding that time out
a little bit you know after edelman made
the uh catch with 28 seconds left you
guys had three plays after that
yeah i feel good about it
[Music]
all right next question zach cox
followed by mount contour
you know there are all sorts of ways
that you can get out of a tough question
if you truly have the discipline and if
you truly have the force of personality
to do it the best option is
just sit there just sit there and say
nothing and eventually the world will
move on and you know it's funny i i give
guys like tom curran a hard time the the
folks in the patriots press corps and i
could hear it in mike reese's voice that
that hesitation that trepidation it's
like walking down the hallway for an
audience with the great and powerful
wizard of oz it and and i'd be the same
way because i've said to kern before why
does no one have the guts to ask him
this question he's like hey you're yeah
feel free feel free to come to the
preschool i was like no thank you no no
i'm not doing it either but but but
there is that quality and uh look no
one's pressing him on
what needs to be pressed
on
the idea of allowing the clock to tick
and tick and tick and tick first and 10
on the 13 with one timeout left
and if they would have taken the time
out as soon as that play ended there
would have been 29 seconds on the clock
as it stood they ran a play they forced
it ball went through the hands of julian
adam in the end zone there was nine
seconds left there was 20 seconds
with that much time in that spot they
would have had more
than two shots after that that first
down play and it worked they got to the
one they had their chance the fact that
they had a chance on a one-play
all-or-nothing opportunity to win
softens
the mistake that was made but clearly it
was a mistake to not call timeout once
they got the ball to the 13 with a
moving clock and also watch cam newton
he's not moving with any real urgency
they could have gotten that play off
even sooner call that time out and and
save as much of those precious few
seconds as you can sharing
yeah and it's so hard to criticize bill
belichick because we know what he he's
done as you said he's the greatest coach
he's like at the super bowl ever they
boo him they boom and he puts up the
hands with the rings that's it
scoreboard that's right that's it that's
it so it's really hard to criticize him
but when it doesn't work when you don't
get in and and if cam newton gets in
we're not talking about this today we're
like hey what a what a great job bill
belichick did by not calling time out
there you let the clock run down seattle
never saw the ball again that was
fantastic but it didn't work so we are
questioning his decision and i think
it's worthy of a question and i'm sure
despite what he said that he's second
guessed himself and it is on the head
coach to call timeouts it's not like
he's given that duty over to steve
belichick his son he's calling the time
out so that was on him and he made that
decision and he's the one who has to
feel good about it if he truly feels
good about it good for him and we can
move on to next week and see if the
patriots can get it done next week
okay we'll move on to the next topic in
the cowboys game it was 39-24 with
roughly five minutes left the cowboys
score touchdown they're down nine points
instead of going for one and making it a
one score game now it would be touchdown
and two point conversion they went for
two they failed keeping it at a two
score game here's coach mike mccarthy
explaining the decision in the aftermath
of what ultimately worked out for the
cowboys but not because of the decision
that was made with five minutes left
the decision to go for two there
is is
simple simple mathematics where
you rather know the you know if it's a
two score game
at the earliest time instead of taking
all the way down to the end and playing
for the two point at the end so
i understand
i can't tell you how many conversations
i've been involved
in in this particular situation but
to go for two there
just to make it clear whether just to
make it clear with a little over four
minutes if we were going to be in a one
score game or two two score game was the
thinking
i get it i understand it i just don't
know that i buy it and to me
psychology is the water's edge of
analytics because you have to look at
the impact on the other team of making
it a one score game versus allowing it
to be a two-score game this was a point
coach dungey made last night when we
were discussing it in a digital taping
that we did then i'm sure the code has
been pasted into a story somewhere at
pft you'll find it you'll see it where
coach dungey says look
if you don't convert that to a pointer
you're taking the heat off of the other
team they know it's a two score game at
that point they have a different
approach they have have a different
mindset they're less likely to be tight
right when they're up two scores with
five minutes to go
whereas if you take the one and you make
it a one score game your chances of
getting the ball back your chances of
scoring that touchdown your chances of
even being being in position to tie it
with a two-point conversion are greater
significantly than if you give the ball
back to the other team down two scores
that's what gets lost in this
new i don't want to say obsession but
the coaches really have swung toward
embracing analytics and that's fine
there's a point though where analytics
has to stop and the broader
circumstances of the game have to be
taken into account shereen
yeah you know mike mccarthy said after
last week when he went forward on fourth
down could have tied the game late with
the zerline chip shot field goal that
the honeymoon was off well it's really
off this week let me just tell you they
are all over mike mccarthy and he better
be happy that they won that game there
were two other decisions in that game
that really could have come back to bite
him too he went had two fake punts in
that game and the first one came early
the first quarter they're only trailing
14 nothing they're deep in their own end
and they and they attempted a fake punt
for for whatever reason and he must have
thought that johnny hecker came with
john fossil because chris jones didn't
make the throw it would have worked but
chris jones didn't make that throw he's
not johnny hecker so there were those
two decisions and then as you said late
that they don't kick the extra point
they try to go for two which you know he
spent this whole year on analytics we
heard about oh the off year i spent my
whole year on analytics his analytics
right now are not working after two
games
i like the aggressiveness but you have
to know when and where to use it in a
game and i just don't think he's figured
that out so far and he better figure it
out in a hurry because they have seattle
coming out this week
and and here's the thing and it's funny
the first fake punt was in the barry
switzer spot right the the 29-yard line
fourth and one
at least barry switzer went for it he
left the offense on the field to get the
one one-yard years before analytics
became a thing
here's the reality
the the numbers that are the product
of you know years and years of plays
being run and these win probabilities
it's all based upon what's happened in
the past it's not based upon who's on
your team or who's on their team it is a
historical calculation with years and
years of down and distances and what
teams did and these are the percentage
based on the past the problem is this
isn't like taking a stack of chips to
the to the craps table and working the
percentages because you're going to run
out of chips quickly you don't have
enough chips to keep going over and over
and over again until the numbers work in
your favor you've only got so many you
can lose before you're gone so you can't
and because i envisioned that some of
these coaches have just given over to it
completely whatever the numbers say
we're gonna do
then we don't have to make the decision
the decisions made ahead of time it's
not my decision we're just going with
the numbers don't blame me we just did
what the numbers said we should do
because these are the numbers and the
numbers never lie the problem is you
don't get enough iterations you don't
get enough bets you don't get enough
opportunities to have it work out your
way if too many of the early ones blow
up in your face and now he's going to be
skittish about it he has to be after
losing these big bets early in his
cowboys coaching career so look here's
the thing i'm all in shireen with the
idea of if you're down 14 and you score
a touchdown if they're you know
depending upon that it's got to be at
the right time of the game i'm not
saying do it in the first half if you're
down 14. but if you're closing in toward
the end of the game and you're down 14
and you score go for two because if you
don't make it you're still down one
score if you make it you can win the
game and run away without having to play
overtime especially if you're on the
road it's a genius move don't play for
overtime play for the win i like it i
also like and chris sims doesn't if
you're up one
and you score a touchdown i love going
for two you make it a two score game if
you convert it game over at that point
depending upon when you do it i just
can't get behind this idea of going for
two when you're down nine because if you
don't make it you've basically conceded
the game and it's like hey we're either
gonna lose now we're gonna lose later
let's use our two-point play and at
least we know right at least we know
that we're going to have to pull a
rabbit out of our butt to try to win
this game oh and by the way they did but
but it's just amazing to me number one
that they ultimately won and number two
that that mccarthy has just this kind of
hair trigger whatever the computer says
is what i'm going to do
i i had finished the story mike even
after they scored the touchdown i'm like
yeah they made it close you know they
they could have had a chance to tie the
game but no they decided to go for two
earlier and they made it close people
who don't watch this game are going to
think well it was a really close game
and then they
somehow someway find a way to recover
the onside kick which is more on the
falcons probably than than on the
cowboys so it was a really good um
onside kick by zerline but here's the
thing mike when these decisions work the
coach is held as a genius and when they
don't we second guess it and always
point to the the onside kick to start
the second half of the super bowl that
sean payton made
and they recover it and that was the
beginning of the end for the colts in
that super bowl that one that to me won
the saints the super bowl but the saints
don't recover that they probably don't
win that game and forever we're talking
about sean payton let one get away what
was he thinking etc etc but we held him
as a genius
perhaps because of that one play or that
one play among other plays but that was
the biggest decision that he's ever made
in his career and he's held as a genius
for it but if it doesn't work it's a
completely different thing so these
coaches are really good when their
players execute and do do the right
things and it turns out in their favor
and and their goats are second guessed
when when it doesn't and so here we are
second guessing some of these coaches
decision yesterday
but here's what i've noticed in recent
years it used to be
that
the once they moved the two-point play
they didn't move it up they moved the
one point back creating
in theory better odds and better chances
of teams to go for two because it was
longer odds slightly to get the one
point
i thought more coaches would embrace it
mike tomlin originally did but the thing
is and the mindset was
you do the conventional thing because if
the conventional thing fails no one's
going to criticize you the
unconventional thing if you do it and it
fails that's when you get criticized
that pendulum has swung now
now the coaches who do the
unconventional thing as long as it's
supported by analytics they trust that
someone out there from the analytics
crowd is going to shout down the people
who say it was stupid to do it because
from an analytics perspective
it makes sense yes it makes sense if
you're going to play 10 000 games it
makes sense we're talking about one game
one moment one season when you're trying
to turn around uh you know years of
frustration and inability of the cowboys
to live up to their potential and you're
trying to win a super bowl during jerry
jones lifetime we don't have 10 000
spins of the of the wheel here to have
it work out our way enough times to
justify doing it that's where the
analytics have to take a back seat and
the problem is there's such an
aggressive analytics mafia out there who
get offended and want to tell us how
dumb we are by bringing human factors
into the equation right you got to know
when to set the numbers down and bring
human factors into the equation and one
of the human factors is some owners
don't have the luxury some coaches don't
have the luxury of playing this out 10
000 times and having the bulk of the
decisions ultimately over time justify
making that decision every time it lands
on your radar screen all right anthony
lynn had a questionable decision for the
la chargers
over time on our own 34 first possession
right was it first possession of the of
overtime possession it was first
possession of overtime right so so they
surrender it they surrender it and well
either way even if it's not first
possession you surrender it and the
chiefs can win it with a field goal they
kicked the ball they punted from their
own 34 fourth and one anthony lin said
he was just trying to extend the game
the problem is you don't give the ball
to patrick mahomes and again whatever
the chart says
and i don't know maybe the chart there
says go for it i think against the
chiefs the chart should say go for it
there
anything you can do in overtime to keep
the ball out of the hands of patrick
mahomes you do
and that that's a no-brainer we saw it
in the afc championship game a couple of
years ago the best way to be packed with
homes in overtime is don't let him get
on the field shireen
absolutely and i had that game yesterday
and i was thinking what are you doing
you just gave the game away i don't care
that the punt took them back to the 25
or wherever they were after that
but you know and i didn't like his
answer after the game he said certainly
we could have given them the ball right
there and the game would have been over
quicker so basically you're saying when
you punted the game was over anyway so
go for it and it was not that long of a
fourth down play you can make that play
you've got to trust justin herbert he
would have been a hero held after that
game if he could have made that play and
they had gone down even to kick a field
goal if the chiefs had come back and
scored a touchdown you're still talking
about justin herbert and how great he
played and we still are he played a
great game but i wanted to see him get
one more chance to at least go down and
get a field goal if not score a
touchdown he had just been so good on
the day
and i think they had a chance to make
that and they didn't give him a chance
to make it and you knew once the chiefs
got the ball back now they did have to
convert a fourth down themselves but and
kick a 58-yard field goal but we're not
talking about they weren't playing
cincinnati and they weren't playing
randy bullock and they got lucky the
week before and if you think that
harrison butker was going to miss a
31-yard field goal i know it wasn't 31
but that's the one that randy bullock
missed it wasn't going to happen they
were going to make a field goal however
long it was he'd made a 58 yarder
earlier in the game he was going to make
that field goal you had to go for it
that's why the best approach to
analytics is that every decision is
informed by the analytics but ultimately
not driven by blind adherence to the
analytics because those numbers were
generated not based upon who's on your
team and who's on their team and one
week it may make sense based on who's on
their team and another week when patrick
mahomes is the quarterback of the other
team
it makes more sense to hold on to the
football no matter what your chart no
matter what your 23 year old mit whiz is
telling you in your ear like john
harbaugh has no matter what anyone says
that's the job of the coach to take all
of those factors and ultimately make a
decision based upon those unique
circumstances and that unique time and
place
that's my position on analytics and i
think it makes sense and i think that's
what the best coaches do including bill
belichick except when he lets the time
run off the clock when he should have
taken i don't know that i don't know
that i don't know that there was
somebody in his ear from mit saying
don't take the time out i just think
that was a good old-fashioned blunder of
judgment by bill belichick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports